foreign
[Music]
hi guys it's Quinn here if you enjoy my
videos consider hitting the like button
it's the only way the YouTube algorithm
really notices me if you'd like to do
more to keep this channel afloat
consider donating through the PayPal
Link in the description or checking out
our patreon thanks guys so much
it is rare that a single three minute
trailer carries this
immensity of themes represented
the theme of Legacy the theme of
conflicts of fanaticism and Faith the
concept of myth making and what it means
to be a True Believer as a dune fan as
someone that has read all of the Frank
Herbert Dune books over and over and
over again as someone that has been
studying this series for years and years
this trailer made me very very excited
and let's break down exactly why
so this trailer opens up with the three
moons of arrakis and there is a
monologue of Paul Atreides talking about
the harkonens in reference to his
family's own Feud with the harkonas
which has been going on for generations
and generations and generations and in
reference to the oppression of the
Freeman to the Freeman the desert isn't
merely a land of resources to be
pillaged it is their home they have a
deep spiritual and mystical connection
to the desert and they also know the
secrets of the desert they know how to
disappear into the desert the emperor
and the harkonans are oppressing the
Freeman because of the existence of
spice melange spice melange is only
found in the Deep deserts of arrakis the
spice extends life heightens awareness
we've heard all this before
so what we are seeing in this trailer
and a huge part of what we see in the
book are Freeman efforts to curtail the
process of collecting spice for the
harkonans the harkonans are in debt at
this point due to the coup against house
Atreides it was very very expensive at
the end of the last movie The Baron
harkonin commands his nephew the Beast
raban to really really squeeze Iraqis
the baron needs to collect as much spice
as he can because he's in the hole and
also he has a quota to keep up with for
the emperor and if you don't know the
intricacies of Dune you know that spice
is also important because it's the fuel
of the universe The Navigators who
navigate ships through outer space need
the spice melange in order to avoid
obstacles without the spice melange
travel throughout the cosmos is
unpractical and extremely dangerous so
if the baron keep up on spice production
that's going to attract the attention of
the lanzarad of chome company and most
importantly of the guild who combined
could easily destroy him so house her
Conan right now is really really under
pressure and the complexity goes even
further than that but this video will be
way too long we also see more of fade
ratha in this trailer fade ratha is The
Baron's nephew and Heir fade rotha is
the favorite over the Beast raban you
can think of fade ratha as the
antithesis to Paul Atreides he's the
anti-atrades he is the anti-paul and as
I said in my breakdown of the last
trailer there was always going to be
this Clash inevitably simply because of
who they were and their positions which
had been set into place really by the
mini Jesuit so we see fade ratha in the
Arena scene which is from the books and
we also see some Eerie figures in the
background and we also see a little bit
of fade ratha in his clash with Paul the
treaties we also get a shot of the Beast
ribbon looking a little bit scared and
when I think about things that could
potentially scare the Beast for Bond I
am drawn to one particular scene in the
book and I will not spoil what that is
but this could potentially be around
that moment one more thing that I was
drawn to is that the baron is
encouraging rabban show me who you are
the reason that was interesting to me is
because the baron is on this journey to
kind of discover who fade ratha is and
if he can actually be the one to succeed
him so he needs to see fade rotha's
chops final thing on the harkonens I
like the shot of giddy Prime and it was
cool to see the baron in his suspensers
so the main theme of the early Dune Saga
is also the main theme of this trailer
it seems which is the construction of
fanaticism and the deification of
leaders we see in the trailer the lady
Jessica asked stilgar do you believe in
Paul and he says there are signs we see
that there is going to be this process
from which stilgar goes from thinking
maybe he could be the one to fully
believing Paul Mount Shai haloud and
then we see his face and he fully
believes and then we have this shot of
stilgar where he looks fully fanaticized
crazed ready to die from muadim fully
believing fully bought in
this is the real power of Jessica's
order the Benny Jesuit they have the
ability to create Legends they have the
ability to produce human Gods I think
what Frank Herbert was saying in putting
this in his book was that the bini
Jesuit are merely exploiting a desire
that already exists within Humanity that
desire for something greater than them
that is why we deify our leaders that is
why we deify historical figures it's
happened again and again and again and
we're seeing it play out now 20 000
years in the future in Dune I want to
move now to Paul and Shawnee now Paul
and Johnny have one of the best tragic
love stories in all of classic science
fiction he calls her his sihaya which in
the Freeman language meant the Desert
Spring Shawnee is integral in Paul's
assimilation into French in society and
Freeman culture
she is his Gateway it is important for
this movie to emphasize their
interactions and their connection and
anybody that's telling you otherwise
doesn't understand the book the
character of chani is extremely
important for Paula trades development
as a character in the first book and
later in the books so it's great to see
proper attention being given to that
aspect of the story as well
also in this trailer we get a clearer
look at the spice Agony scene so we see
Jessica in taking the Water of Life so
we talked about this in the last trailer
breakdown in Freeman Society there are
wild Reverend mothers women that have
some of the powers of the Benny Jesuit
this is one of them
through the spice Essence someone
trained in the mini Jesuit way can
unlock their genetic memory
that is what we are witnessing in this
scene and I am very excited to see it
because a lot occurs in the scene a lot
more than you might think from hearing
that description but I won't spoil it
entirely
also in this trailer we got our very
first look at Christopher Walken as the
emperor I was really excited to see this
and they have gone with a more minimal
approach for the emperor visually at
least but as far as what Christopher
Walken is bringing to this role from
what I can tell he seems cold cunning
and calculating when iriland says I
think Paul Atreides is still alive
he immediately accepts it what I see on
his face in the scene is acceptance and
then Defiance now what do I do about
this how do I squash this bug so I think
the emperor will have a very cold
menacing atmosphere about him just from
the trailer
so now let's move to Paul himself
now that Paul is in the Deep desert
his powers are manifesting
you can see that his eyes are now blue
within blue for most of the trailer that
happens with spice saturation it
naturally occurs when you spend a lot of
time in the Deep desert
so Paul's powers are Awakening he is
having visions of the future but
everything that he is seeing is dark he
is not seeing a path forward that does
not have dark Omens we're shown his
father's doogle ring and then we're
shown an image of his father's portrait
being burned it's the same vision that
he had in the first movie in the tent
with Jessica
Legions of Freeman marching at the
banner at The Shrine of his father's
skull paraphrasing of course
Paul
has the potential through prescience to
see multiple paths in the future but
there are certain actions and we really
really see this we learn this more
explicitly in the third book Children of
Dune there are certain actions that are
so great that they can lock you onto a
specific path
and that is what Paul has perhaps
unwittingly done to himself
by join joining the Freeman he is on he
has locked himself and the Freeman onto
a specific path
and
it's a dark path
yes he may gain Vengeance for house
Atreides yes the Freeman May triumph
over their oppressors
but then what happens
there's a dark aura that encircles this
entire thing
so there's a lot of moments from the
book that I see in this trailer a couple
of quotes I specifically Like the quote
uh he who can destroy a thing has the
control over it we see in the trailer
the bombing of The Shield wall through
use of atomics which is in the book we
see the rallying of the Freeman we see
the weaponization of shy halud we see
the rejoining of Gurney halleck and Paul
Atreides and it just all in all looks
beautiful it looks epic it looks like a
continuation of the first movie it looks
like you can watch them back to back and
it feels like you're just watching the
same film except now it's the climax I
couldn't be more excited for Doom part 2
to drop in November thank you guys so
much for watching make sure you leave a
like And subscribe for more Quinn's
ideas
by the way I did launch a podcast we
will be releasing episodes every Friday
it is called Cosmic Chronicles you can
check it out by clicking the link in the
description thank you so much guys
[Music]
thank you